slowly but surely we're getting more and
more denials from Trump associates that
are falling apart when it comes to their
interactions with Russian actors
diplomat agents we've now learned that
Jeff sessions did have conversations
with the Russian ambassador Sergei Kiss
lyac about Donald Trump's campaign at
least according to the Ambassador
himself first jeff sessions claimed he
had no meetings with russians at all
then it came out okay he had meetings
with russians but they were very brief
hellos they were not campaign related
meetings nothing about the campaign was
discussed we've now learned that Russian
ambassador Sergei Kiss react reported
two different conversations with jeff
sessions to his superiors who of course
was Donald Trump's foreign policy
adviser during the campaign these
conversations were intercepted between
by US intelligence and they were again
kiss react telling his superiors yes
we've talked about campaign stuff we've
talked about policy related stuff one US
official said that Jeff sessions who
again remembered sessions testified that
he had no recollection of an of such an
encounter kiss react reportedly said
that he did have conversations about
Russian policy sessions has repeatedly
said campaign related issues were not
discussed it was only in my capacity as
a US senator that I met with Sergey kiss
react and kiss lyac is saying oh no we
had conversations about policy related
to Russia and this could lead to even
bigger problems for Jeff Sessions as
Attorney General Donald Trump already
said a few date a few days ago that if
he had known that sessions was going to
refuse himself from anything Russia
related he wouldn't have selected
sessions to be Attorney General in the
first place and now we have to wonder
number one whether this is going to
further push a possible request for
sessions his resignation and number two
I wonder if sessions is being
deliberately set up to ultimately end up
resigning now you might say well maybe
kids lyac lied to his own superiors
I guess it's possible right kids lyac
could have lied to his superiors and
said oh yeah I talked about policy stuff
with sessions maybe to try to impress
his superiors doesn't seem hugely likely
to me you could make the the
hypothetical that if kiss react
suspected his phone calls
with his superiors were being surveilled
or that emails were being surveilled he
could have deliberately lied about this
merely to confuse American intelligence
I mean it's possible but it doesn't
really fit into everything else we've
learned about this situation
sure kiss Lea could be out there trying
to deliberately mislead or brag even I
guess we really don't know when it comes
to his own credibility but what we do
know is that Jeff sessions has no
credibility on this matter because he
lied about meeting with any Russian
officials when he was going through his
confirmation process in front of the
Senate he was under oath during that and
I think most people at this point think
that he perjured himself even in a
colloquial sense yeah we don't know
about this that's the the growing
question which is is this perjury right
and unless Jeff Sessions truly didn't
remember it appears that it would be but
again how do you prove someone did
remember something it is very difficult
and this is why perjury is a very very
difficult charge to prosecute which is
why it's so rarely even brought forward
it also seems so obvious that they would
talk about the Trump campaign or they
would talk about Russian policy I mean
what are you going to do during that
meeting just you know have pleasantries
and discussion adoption for the entire
meeting it would be shocking if they
didn't right that's why it's so hard to
believe do you think Pat that Trump
could be playing this 40 chess that some
people I don't even know if seriously or
jokingly say he sometimes plays setting
up Jeff sessions to resign because he's
not pleased with him and then I guess he
could take further control over the
Russia investigation I don't know maybe
so I thought it was really questionable
that Jeff Sessions decided not to resign
after that Donald Trump New York Times
interview came out and Trump attacked
him but also you talked about four
dimensional chess it's really not too
crazy to talk about four dimensions when
Donald Trump doesn't really understand
the forward progress of time well with a
lot of things related to what's going on
with the Trump administration many of
their assertions own
make sense if you believe time does not
work in a forward path right you would
have to have a different conception of
how time progresses to make many of
these Trump assertions true
we'll see what ultimately happens with
sessions that are now